hello everyone thank you for
waiting for
you come to the press conference
I invite the President of the
European Council to take the floor good evening to
each and everyone we read this evening
a long debate a substantial
debate a serious debate also because we
we woke up this morning on the
European continent to a
different world a world in which
the rules-based order is
shaken is attacked in an
extremely painful way it was
an opportunity for us to affirm the
strong condemnation of this
military aggression  of this war which was
started by abusing and using
false pretexts and bad excuses
we also had the opportunity once
again to affirm the unity the unity of
the european union the unity of the
member states  unity with our partners
with our allies and our friends all over
the world to defend international law
to defend these times
re-establish rules that offer the
most guarantees for  r peace for
security and for stability the
second point is the
political decision that was taken to initiate
an additional package of
massive sanctions and painful
sanctions against the Russian regime we had
the opportunity with  all the plates and
to reaffirm this firmness and that in
connection with our partners were ali it will be
up to the council of the union
to legally implement the
political orientations which were
decided this evening we also mentioned
the question of support for  the
ukrainian people for ukraine the mother of
mobilizing both humanitarian
support funding capacities
we also had
the opportunity
to hear an address by the
ukrainian president on the occasion of this european council
it was a moment of  seriousness a moment
of dignity a moment of composure
also or with google frankness he
told us the message he
wanted to send us in the
extremely circumstances  difficult and
painful that we are
currently experiencing in ukraine he you we
want to underline and he is all the
dignity and courage of the
Ukrainian people who are
currently facing a tragic situation they
are women men from families who
are bruised who are shaken who are
directly affected by the horror of
an air of war which we all hoped would be
impossible on the European continent
a few days ago with all the
diplomatic attempts that had been
mobilized to roll back
finally, this threat we had the opportunity
to also address a number
of other subjects the importance of
mobilizing support for the eastern flank of
the european union of course closely linked
to the weather there will be a summit
tomorrow this question  this could be
discussed again, but we are
also preparing solidarity with the countries most
directly concerned in order
to be able to mobilize the
humanitarian aid which is necessary.  ires he
also gave me the means to
ensure that refugees could be
welcomed in a dignified and
suitable manner finally this situation
also shows to what extent the debate
which has been open for a few years
now on this ambition to
develop a europe which  either more
oriented towards sovereignty or
strategic autonomy takes on its full
dimension when confronted with
what we are witnessing today two
examples are intended to illustrate the need
to be committed in the field
of energy to reduce our dependence
for  reduce our capacity
for independence strategy in this
area we have pensions ancion it was
an orientation that has been taken for
some time to have an in-
depth debate in march
at the european council which will take place in
brussels on this subject on  the two
proposals are drawn up by the
European commission this point has
obviously been addressed this evening and then
there the importance  this to continue to act to
strengthen security
capabilities defense capabilities of course
time is the cornerstone of our
security we believe that strong alliances
are based on strong strong wingers
and this is also the sense
of ambition  that we have finally a
last point the question of
the international commitment we see
well that it is important to mobilize the
international community to mobilize
all the countries in the world which 3 to an
order based on rules which believe in
the international law  which 3 to the charter
of the united nations to guarantee
stability, security and respect for
one another and it is in this that we
intend to be so extremely
committed to trying to progress so
that we can ensure that the
international community either firm
or standing up or mobilized to defend
these principles which are
extremely essential to us and
here we are some of the elements that  that I
wanted to share with you it is a
European Council was not a
trivial European Council it was not an
ordinary meeting it was a meeting where
we measured the seriousness the
awareness of living a moment which can
be represented as a  turning point and for
which it will be up to our
generation in europe with our
partners all over the world to
make the right choices the wise choices
to show courage in the short term
but also in the medium and long term
thank you sir
thank you
are the  chipmunks leaves europe
falling innocent women and children of the
fiefdoms of the af many times so de sa
pince in thirty one title of vice
president putin thing to bring back
watch you
need is fully flash a wave new creme
index lighthouse of men on the skins  100
creations eyed peas
baptized also said opinionway instance
united tonight you need pony life in
konami there are too many taxes no commitment
maximum the impact in law political economy
d  e leak in the end this sector
is when angie
transport services sector force export control and
export crazy finance
who do not believe in
it
energy sector which economic and oriane
which
experts
by making the formation of
which
export
connectivity
horns as
benign of the ssn  canada and sorrows of the
world at
this point and there
exists to hook technology yes three
axes carry a technology and need to
bill of prospects I connect
catenaccio technology and finally
consider promises and related
groups and business people will no
longer serious
crisis of  image
australia
exactly the opposite yes aboard a
ship united and luiz determined to
conclude me stephens indeed mark king of
new era yes massive eric
fox analysis
poutine thong and friendly gerpinnes
country to history and weed road map of
the  re up by force who actually masks
as the
fifth president Mr.
President of the Republic I
invite you thank you very much  up good evening, ladies
and gentlemen,
we therefore held this European Council
in the context that was recalled by
Mr. President, I, Madam
President, women, moreover, that
not of a crisis but of a war and the
choice that was  made by President
Putin to launch a series of
massive military operations and did not target as he
said himself a few hours ago on
the donbass
but a massive military operation
which killed several
hundred civilians
Ukrainians, as
President Céline confirmed a few hours ago,
who himself
faced with this war situation,
we must draw all the
conclusions that
President Putin's choice is on the one hand to
want to stutter European history
and bring us back to
logics of the worst of confrontation the
second is to flout all the
principles all the principles that
preside over international law on
charters and treat sovereign sign  ed
by russia in recent decades
faced with this
choice first we decided to anticipate
and remain united and we have done so
from the beginning
our unity we first designed
to
discuss and give every chance to
the  diplomacy without naivety without
concession through a demanding dialogue that
we have conducted within the framework
of the Normandy 10 format
with Germany is also through the
contacts that several
European colleagues and that
our institutions have been able to make in
recent weeks
it is the deliberate choice  of the
Russian President for not seizing this
path unity and preparation is
also what presided over the work carried out
by the committee and I would like to thank
Madam President and her teams and
who ensured that during the month which has
just  all the weeks that
have just passed
the european union has worked
closely with all of its
british american canadian allies
to design all the s  anctions, of
which a new stage this evening was acts
and politically by all the
heads of state and government, all of this
has been prepared and designed and so this evening
we have decided I will not go back
to the list which has just been detailed
by mr president madam
president very clear which is a
first response
the european union has therefore decided
together to inflict very severe costs
on moscow on both
people and sectors they will
also be supplemented by government measures
and j  I have this morning
requested several works, in particular
on personal property and a series of
two personalities in addition to these
measures, these sanctions will also target
the Belarusian regime which is complicit
in this Russian offensive and I want to
insist on this point in view of
recent developments  of the last few
weeks
the second element that we have
all acted on together on which I wanted to
come back here is obviously the support  n
to ukraine unprecedented economic aid
to ukraine has been recorded
with the adoption of a macro
financial package of 1.2 billion euros
it will go further and continue to
mobilize all financial and
materials I will try to say that
France will contribute to this
additional effort with 300 million euros
for the Ukrainian economy and we
are ready to continue to deliver
military and support materials to the
population as I was able to tell the
president  and the izk
third element is that of the
protection of europeans
and
all nations and peoples
military protection
i confirmed today we
notified nato and i will have the opportunity to
go into  details tomorrow at the
summit as far as we want
france will continue to fully play its
role of reassuring nato allies
by sending a new
contingent to estonia within the wind presence
has been strengthened by anticipating its
share  Participation in the Baltic Sky Police
from March and
also accelerating its deployment in Romania
beyond that I remind you that we
are the framework nation of vegf and
obviously we will play our role
I reminded them we will be alongside
our  infallibly allied
economic protection also with
the rapid adoption of measures to
deal with this exceptionally serious crisis,
in particular with regard
to energy prices, so that European citizens
and our businesses are
fully protected and then protection
of our democracy of our
public opinions in the context that has
just been recalled with additional initiatives
that we will take in
terms of cyber in the fight
against disinformation
which is being propagated on
social networks and by several
relays  of Russian propaganda on European soil
finally to conclude I will join
President Michel, whom I also thank
for  all the initiatives that he has
coordinated taken in recent days and
identified in recent weeks is
what President dallas was able to say
we have there I believe fully
demonstrated the need for our europe
to accelerate its sovereignty agenda
tragic pond of history
come back
the war is there on our soil
and therefore if need be to have the
demonstration that europe is not
simply a consumer market
but indeed a power which must think about
its energy independence
its climate transition  by itself
which must think of a Europe of defense
capable of protecting its borders its
citizens and of projecting itself towards its
allies
among other things and obviously also
technological sovereignty
the war that we are
living through demonstrates
this to us cruelly it is  why we will continue
the agenda initiated in recent months in
recent years to accelerate it further
because we have the demonstration that d  in
the tragic times that we are living in,
europe has no choice but to
become again, perhaps, to become
dare i say a power, thank you,
thank you, sir, president,
irini and the buttocks, pelisse, coach of the
stadium,
the visions of the greek public  and
news agencies that
asked if you feel betrayed by
vladimir putin because he did not
keep his pros but he started a
war and if you are still in favor
of a dialogue and under what conditions
if he  please thank you
we have, as I said, done everything
so that
the diplomatic channel can prevail
and I remind you that on the
Ukrainian question the Minsk agreements
prevailed was the framework approved by
all the parties and the Normandy format the
one that was authoritative  and
legitimacy
until a few hours before the
launch
of the operations
the recognition of two
illegitimate republics then the
military operations we were still discussing
the details with President Putin  of the
implementation of the minsk agreements so
yes there was duplicity yes there was a
conscious deliberate choice by president putin to launch
the war when we could still
negotiate peace
in this context
the situation and the one we
know it  first of all calls for
unconditional support for the Ukrainian people
for their authorities their president
it is the support that we provide
it is that of solidarity between
Europeans
it involves a series of sanctions
and measures that we have just recalled
but it involves  also to know how to
keep the channels open so that
as soon as possible
the ceasefire can be decided and
the hostilities stopped because today
as I reminded it it is civilians
who are killed here is the situation here is
how I see it today
but very clearly the choice was
made deliberately by the
Russian president to go to war and therefore we
must also draw the express consequences from
this.  on mac os x
[Music]
7 to 10 10 demonstration and isis green
power for all of us to learn
double science train the deep end says either
you have it easy yes that because michèle and
jean green
transition specialists peter  ring is so important
to the most wanted ten films the cross
of transition wears him stars
watkins many countries in sit in a day
to see how to be possible to shorten
half time of the derby facing the beach at
the doctor the icons and eugene  says swann
v8 leak to huy option example of
being monsters east is we need to
develop desired demi
gigoteur indeed the one instrumentalize been used
concerning face to fus to formats and
touching instruments to
a europe that unites
global supply
chain
rice find you  know and animals
and the scene it
shitov tout locatif act
i die today to depend
la chine face aux young
as
we have to do everything to reduce the
cheap and dancing à ce qu elle dit
working in the last week's tout co  ms
swiss txt
yes all that you need
gigas grinders formula is simple and
complicated said cable has crossed the bar
of 6 chargers
and a half of long term
gas and
adventure
line
gigault
it can be blood transport
by
bus
tf1
I have one last question  by mathieu
coach bfm
mathieu
hello madam president hello
gentlemen presidents mathieu coatch
bfm tv mr macron you spoke to
vladimir poutine this evening can you
give us some information on
the content of this interview in what
state of mind was  the Russian president
this evening and does it still make
sense to dialogue with him when he
flouted international law, you said,
by starting this
war jean yves le drian calls him
dictators do you use this term and
then another question a
humanitarian crisis has already started
is france committed to welcoming
ukrainian refugees who will flock to
europe in the coming days i
v  First of all, we would like to thank you for the
humanitarian crisis that you mentioned. We
have been discussing it this evening for a
very long time. I think I
can say that there is unanimity in
recalling here, in fact, the solidarity
of all Europeans and, moreover,
this crisis.
believe reminds some and
some around the table who had been
able to show less solidarity
when the migratory pressure came
from other borders of europe
that it is good for europe to be
totally united and responsible
together and therefore the  France like all
the other European countries will take its
part and I can here confirm it to you and
obviously to both assist the
Ukrainian population and for all
those who were on
Ukrainian soil and would find themselves on
European Union soil  come in
solidarity and be able to welcome and therefore
we will do it in a European way in a
responsible and united coordinated way
then I had a
quick direct frank exchange with the president  nt
poutine
at the request of president céline ski
just now to first ask him to
stop the fighting as soon as possible
and above all
to suggest that he discuss it ask him to
discuss with president céline ski
whose it was  asks this one
not managing to reach him
and therefore I have the faith to pass this message
from France to the Russian Federation in
a clear way I also transmitted this
message from the Ukrainian
President to the Russian President
it did not produce any  effect you can clearly see
for the moment since the
Russian president has chosen war, but I
think it is my
responsibility first of all to take such initiatives
when they are requested by ukraine
and then
while condemning everything in  sanctioning
while continuing to decide to act to
leave this path open so that the
day when the conditions can be
met we can obtain a
cessation of hostilities
for the Ukrainians and for the
Ukrainians
thank you sir  eur the president the
president is almost closed